welcome so i've done this series of
presentations about uh housing and and
at least my thesis on why housing prices
might have gone up and and how you
should maybe on simple terms think about
the rent versus buy decision but one
thing that's happened a lot of people
said oh sal you're making
oversimplifying assumptions you're
assuming interest-only loans um you're
not taking you're not factoring in the
tax deductions of mortgages etcetera of
interest on your mortgage which i did
but i did make some simplifying
assumptions so that we could kind of do
back of the envelope math and just think
about what the main drivers are when you
think about renting versus buying but it
is fair you really um you know that's
just kind of a first cut you really
should do a multi-line model
trying to figure out what could happen
to you and then tweak your assumptions
and really figure out what's going to
happen to you if housing appreciates
depreciates if interest rates change if
you put
10 percent down or 20 down or whatever
so with that in mind i've constructed
this model what i call that this is the
home purchase model and you can download
it yourself and play with it i think
this will prove to be useful for you you
can download it at khan academy.org
downloads
slash buy rent dot xls it's an excel
spreadsheet so if you have excel you
should be able to access it and maybe
you want to follow along while you watch
this video so just khan academy dot org
i don't know if you can read this on
youtube downloads d-o-w-n-l-o-a-d-s
slash buy rent dot xls
so once you download it let me explain
what what i assumed in the model
so
the yellow what i did in yellow both
this bright yellow and this less bright
yellow is these are our assumptions
these are the things that are going to
drive the model and tell us
whether over and i calculated over 10
years over 10 years whether we will do
better
of renting versus buying
so here and and and so if you download
this model and want to play with it
yourself just
unless you are fairly sophisticated with
excel only the only things you should
change are the things in yellow
everything else is calculated and it's
driven by these inputs so of course what
matters in a home well the purchase
price matters right so you just input it
there the down payment matters you could
if you want you can just write you know
like i wrote 20 of whatever the purchase
price is so you can you know you could
write your the exact number or you could
just leave it the way i did it and
whatever
the down payment percentage is it'll
calculate it this is the interest rate
you assume this is the principal
amortization so principal amortization
just means well if i just keep paying
this mortgage after how long is the
entire principal amount not just the
interest how long is the entire
principal amount going to be paid off in
so essentially 30-year
a 30-year fixed-rate loan has a 30-year
principal amortization if you have a
10-year loan you would put 10 here this
is the property tax rate this is what i
assume because i live in california and
in most areas of california that's the
property tax this is why i assume about
annual maintenance that's just an
assumption that some houses might be
less might be more that's up for you to
decide this is housing association dues
maybe if you live in a community that
has a shared golf course or a shared
pool or something put it at zero if you
don't
this is annual insurance for things like
hazard insurance and flood insurance or
earthquake insurance or whatever
insurance you need where you live and
then this bright yellow i say what is
the assumed annual appreciation of the
house itself and this is a huge
assumption that's why i made it that's
why i put it into this bold this bold
yellow color because we'll see later in
this video that to some degree to some
degree that assumption
is is one of the biggest drivers of
assumption you could say that the model
is very very very sensitive to that
assumption
here this is your
assumed marginal income tax rate and why
does that matter well because you can
deduct your the interest that you spend
on your on your mortgage and also you
can deduct actually the property tax um
so if if you can deduct a hundred
dollars in interest and property tax
if your marginal tax rate is 30 percent
so that means you know
at what rate are you being taxed on
every incremental dollar if it's 30 that
means 100 deduction will save you thirty
dollars if your marginal tax rate is
twenty percent a hundred dollar
deduction will save you twenty dollars
so that's where that comes into play
the two percent that's general inflation
and this what what this assumption
drives is well there's going to be some
inflation on things like housing
association dues annual maintenance
insurance and so this what you assume
about what is just the general rate of
inflation in our model that's actually
going to drive how these grow over the
life of of your loan
and then once you type in all of these
things the monthly mortgage payment is
calculated i assume that the interest
compounds once a month
you can if you know your
geometric series you can go in there and
you can tweak it around so it compounds
more frequently or less frequently but
my understanding is that most mortgages
compound monthly
and then this right here so this is
everything that's driving the buying a
home decision
now these assumptions are
are so that we can make a comparison to
well what if instead of you know using
that down payment to buy a house
what if we actually just save that down
payment put in the bank and rent a house
instead so
this is cost of renting a similar home
this is the annual rental price
inflation
and i would argue to some degree that
rental price inflation over the long
term should not be that different than
housing price inflation because to some
degree rental is is kind of the earnings
on a on a home and if and if earnings
increase and the overall asset doesn't
increase then your return increases or
the other way around your return would
decrease but anyway don't get too
complicated
and then this is the six percent i just
assume it's six percent but you could
you can change it this is what you
assume that you can get uh on your cash
so if i don't if i don't put the hundred
fifty thousand dollar down deposit on
the home and i put it in you know i
don't know maybe i'm a good investor i
could put in the stock market maybe i
can get 20 a year um or maybe i'm really
risk averse and i uh you know i put it
in in government bonds and i get four
percent a year so this is the assumption
that you get on on that and it actually
should be an after tax return on that
cash so
if i if my tax rate is 30 percent and i
think i can get 10 of the stock market i
should actually put a seven percent here
so you know we we want to make sure that
we're completely accurate for taxes
so now let me explain the rest of the
model to you
and i want to make sure that i can fit
it all within this
this window
actually let me just
squeeze this a little bit
this is doing this on youtube as a
excel on youtube is a new thing for
me no no that's not what i wanted to do
so let me unfreeze window
unfreeze
okay
so now i can show you the rest of the
model so all those assumptions that we
did
that drives this model and let me freeze
the window right here
window freeze pane okay that should make
things a little bit easier
so this is the buying scenario up to
line 40.
this says okay at period zero what is
the home value and and don't type in
anything here it's all automatically
calculated so period zero what is your
home value and then it and then it uses
essentially the appreciation numbers and
each period is essentially a month and i
actually wrote that down here and then
it figures out what is the value of your
the market value at home and it's
completely driven by that appreciation
number
this right here is the debt or
essentially the principal payment on
your on your mortgage or how much do you
owe to the bank and as you see as months
go by
when you pay the mortgage note and i and
i show that right here this mortgage
payment some amount of that which is
line 33 the principal paid some of that
goes to decrease the amount you owe
and then a lot of it especially
initially goes to be actually the
interest on the amount you owe and then
obviously when we if you've watched the
the
video on introduction to balance sheets
your equity in the home is the value of
the home
minus the debt
or minus what you owe the bank so this
actually calculates your equity or
essentially so one way to view this
actually say well
what what am i worth or what what is
this investment worth to me at that
point
and all of this so these are kind of the
important numbers in the home buying
scenario it's driven by you know this
interest on debt it's calculated by what
interest rate you assume
times the the debt you owe and the
period before the mortgage payment we
calculated that before using our
mathematical knowledge of geometric
series
the the paid principle that's going to
be the mortgage payment minus your
interest
insurance payment it's on a monthly
basis right so we essentially took
whatever our our annual insurance
payment was and we divided by 12 but
then we grow it
by the rate of inflation on a monthly
basis so we took the inflation rate
divided by 12 and we multiplied by each
of these months
the housing association dues that's once
again this is on a monthly basis so we
just took your assumption divided by 12
maintenance same thing property tax same
thing although
i assume that your house gets reassessed
so you're in a state where every year um
the the assessor or every several years
the assessor comes says oh your house is
worth more now so i'm going to raise
your taxes that's not the case in a lot
of parts of california but it's a lot
it's the case in many parts of the u.s
so actually to some degree this pro the
dollar value of the property tax is
driven by this home value assumption up
here
this income tax saving from interest
deduction this is assuming that at that
marginal tax rate you can deduct the
property tax and the interest on the
debt and then this is the total cash
outflow after adding back the income tax
savings so this is essentially how much
cash goes out the door even after the
tax saving every month in the buying
scenario that's what that is
so hopefully that makes a little bit of
sense so what we want to do is we want
to figure out okay you could do that you
could buy the house put 150 000
down um and every month put this much
out and and as you see that that number
grows the mortgage is the same but a lot
of these expenses grow with inflation
but i want to compare that to what
happens if i take that exact amount of
cash after adjusting for how much money
i get back from taxes and if i said well
i am going to use that cash to pay my
rent
and any other expenses associated with
renting which really aren't much to pay
my rent and then put the rest in the
bank
so what we're saying is well that
assumption was that you could rent a
similar house for twenty five hundred
dollars maybe right maybe wrong it's up
for you to play with
and and of course it grows with
inflation slowly obviously your rent
doesn't increase every month but i
assume it does fairly continuously it's
a reasonable assumption i think although
you could change it you can make it only
step up every every year excuse me
and then this line down here tells us
the savings while renting or how much uh
and i'm not saying the savings like from
like a you know something's on sale so i
save money but your savings in terms of
how much you have in the bank so if you
rent it instead of putting that 150 000
as a down payment you could have put it
in the bank so that would be your
savings account at period zero and then
your savings account at period one would
be this
amount of money and how whatever return
you got it plus the difference between
your cash out from buying a home and
your rent
so this is your savings
so what i do in the video in the in the
in this model and i could show you i
could i could scroll through
multiple periods
you know this this model goes it
actually goes as far as excel would let
me but the average house if anyone who's
traded mortgage bonds will tell you the
average house has a
the average mortgage loan has a 10-year
expected life and because that's when on
average people tend to move or refinance
so i what i do is i figure out well
be given your assumptions and whatever
you can make your own assumptions given
your assumptions
what is
your home value
so let me make sure i can get to that
so given your assumptions what this
calculates is what tells you what the
home value is after 10 years
your debt after 10 years your home
equity after 10 years and then it
assumes you were to sell your house
because that's what the average american
does after 10 years and so what is the
transaction cost you pay six percent to
a broker hopefully that won't be the
case in ten years and the intermediate
and then the and the internet will
disintermediate real estate brokers but
who knows i apologize to if you are a
broker um
and and and and then this line line 54
that tells you
what the net cash is if you sell your
house at a market price you pay the
broker
this number right here is is much
simpler to some degree it just tells you
well let's say you decided not to buy
the house given all your assumptions how
much would you have saved in the bank at
that time
and so this number right here
this number is the difference between
those two numbers in 10 years discounted
back to today
discounted back to today
and actually i meant to present value it
but
did i present value these numbers oh no
i didn't so actually this was meant to
be the present value i'm going to
correct that before you actually play
with the model right now i just took the
10-year value so this is the value in
year 10. this is the difference between
the two the present value would be if
you discount this by some discount rate
whatever you think probably the
inflation rate and it would tell you in
today's money what is the benefit or the
advantage of buying versus renting
anyway i've spent 14 minutes of your
time i encourage you to to download this
model uh play with it and then work out
the assumptions because i think that's
that's the important thing you know some
people they'll make some set of
assumptions say aha i need i should rent
or they'll say aha i should buy but they
don't realize that
they made some assumptions that although
it looks really reasonable you know like
let's say i make this three percent
annual appreciation assumption right
that doesn't seem crazy but it's amazing
how much it'll change the model if you
make that three percent into a one
percent or if you make it you know into
i don't know even a negative one or
negative two percent it's completely
possible it's happened before in the
past um that you have flat real estate
prices uh for a significant period of
time even 10 years
and actually most of the studies show
that real estate over the last hundred
years has actually roughly grown on real
terms maybe one or two percent um so
actually one or two percent here isn't
that isn't that uh conservative and
actually especially after a big real
estate boom
may be prudent
so play with these assumptions and i
think it will give you an intuition of
what are the what are the real drivers
and another big thing you know sometimes
you don't rent a similar home you would
rent a smaller home so that would be a
different type of savings in their
trade-offs there but anyway hopefully
you'll find uh this model useful i think
i think you know
it should be when people this is the
biggest investment of their life they
should do serious analysis
when they think about how they want to
approach it and i'd like to think that
this is fairly serious analysis is about
as serious as you can get
so enjoy see in the next video